retour sur un record historique ce soir
celui de la rémunération des grands
patrons voilà pour le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
de la précarité liée après la crise
sanitaire à la flambée des prix enfin le
député communiste pierre Daredevil
député des Bouches-du-Rhône qui suit ces
sujets à l'Assemblée nationale va nous
rejoindre dans un tout petit instant
mais d'abord l'état des lieux pour mieux
comprendre Stéphane si j'ai bien compris
la précarité que le président voulait
éradiquer ne fait qu'augmenter
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir messieurs si
j'ai bien compris ce soir alors si j'ai
bien compris l'hiver ça commence
seulement dans un mois les Restos du
Coeur donc ouvrent leur 38e campagne et
il constate qu'il y a 12% ces chiffres
que vous sur lequel vous insistez de
gens en plus qui viennent solliciter
leur aide donc ça 12% c'est un chiffre
on est à la télé c'est vrai que ça se
traduit ici par des images qui touchent
peut-être plus nos émotions donc hier je
pense à Paris ou une association
distribuée des repas des paniers
alimentaires à des étudiants qui sont
parmi les plus touchés c'est quand même
impressionnant ces images à chaque fois
d'ailleurs alors donc c'est vrai qu'on
voit ça on les regardant ça suffit sans
doute plus les leçons il y a quand même
des chiffres qui sont eux aussi assez
éloquents il y a une autre association
qui s'appelle le Secours Catholique qui
a produit une grosse étude sur l'état de
la pauvreté en France hier soir 900
000 par personne en France par année ils
en ont interagé 46 000 et il est
ressorti un chiffre 5 euros par jour
alors à quoi ça correspond on écoute
si je peux vous donner un chiffre qui
peut vous donner une idée on calcule ce
qui s'appelle le reste pour vivre le
reste pour vivre c'est une fois qu'on a
toutes les factures le loyer les
assurances etc il reste en moyenne
aujourd'hui parmi les personnes qu'on
accueille il leur reste 5 euros par jour
et par personne 5 euros par jour et par
personne ça veut dire pour les
transports l'hygiène l'alimentation etc
donc on nous dit il manque d'argent donc
forcément on comprend que les
associations d'aide alimentaire se
disent ce qu'il faudrait c'est plus
d'argent en tout cas le Secours
populaire par la voix de l'âme
représente tant disait là en l'état
actuel il faudrait que on ait une aide
de 200 millions d'euros voilà alors que
répond le gouvernement elle répond bah
pas question non certainement pas pas
200 millions vous êtes fous mais quand
même c'est pas pour autant qu'on ne va
pas faire un geste donc Elisabeth borne
était venu dans une banque alimentaire à
Reims elle avait fait cette annonce
c'est 60 millions d'euros que nous
allons mobiliser en 2023 il s'agit
évidemment de pouvoir apporter une
alimentation en quantité suffisante mais
aussi des produits de qualité alors
c'est là que ça devient un peu politique
le gouvernement dit 60 millions d'autres
réclamaient de sang donc n'a-t-il
panneau voilà elle qui voudrait qu'on
dépense plus pour l'aide alimentaire
disait le compte n'est pas célèbre un
slogan reprenne les insoumis en ce
moment le compte n'y est pas le calcul
n'est pas bon c'est ce que disait Louis
Boyard quand il s'adressait les
ministres de l'enseignement supérieur à
l'écoute
calculs ne sont pas bons commençons
contredis par les files d'attentes qui
s'allonge distribution alimentaire car
aujourd'hui être étudiant c'est être
pauvre être étudiant c'est souvent
enchaîné les galères et les petits
boulots alors quand les parcelles
arrivent comment parler d'égalité entre
ceux qui ont la chance d'être aidé et
les autres donc c'est lui qui monte hein
ces interventions de manière punchy pour
les rendre plus efficaces sur les
réseaux sociaux on y est pas alors le
gouvernement a aussi pris d'autres
initiatives mais bien sûr le
gouvernement n'est pas resté sans rien
faire on s'en doute bien donc regardez
on parlait des 60 millions mais d'autres
initiatives on cherche des points précis
à avoir un argent en fléchés de manière
efficace donc 10 millions pour des repas
1 € dans les cantines on l'a annoncé
récemment 10 millions pour les
associations d'aide alimentaire aux
étudiants voilà ça fait des ça fait
toujours pas 200 millions quand même
un autre argument quand même c'est qu'on
a quand même aussi beaucoup dépensé en
France notamment le bouclier tarifaire
sur l'énergie la ristourne à la pompe
énormément d'aide pour franchir la
période covid donc résultat aujourd'hui
en France on est quand même un peu
protégé par le fait que l'inflation
finalement et moins élevé dans notre
pays que dans la plupart des pays
d'Europe et ça c'est c'est aussi de
l'argent qui a déjà dépensé le
gouvernement résultat le président
Macron n'est pas fier évidemment mais je
disais que quand on se fait toujours
pareil quand on se compare on se dit que
par rapport aux autres pays on n'a pas
avoir honte
on a ensuite un modèle social on protège
plus que les copains pendant le covid on
a plus protégé c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on en est sorti plus fort avec un
taux de pauvreté qui ne sait pas
aggraver alors le taux de pauvreté ne
fait pas un grammaire je viens de dire
le contraire la hausse doit
fréquentation donc en fait il fait
référence le chiffre de l'INSEE et les
chiffres de l'INSEE disent eux que non
ça ne sait pas aggraver enfin les
derniers chiffres disponibles ils disent
en tout cas qu'on peut pas vraiment
constater d'aggravation
justement mené des politiques dans ce
sens là et pourtant
vous allez voir que vous on l'a en train
on était sur la partie est-ce qu'il
faudrait pas en faire plus et des
parties qui disent peut-être en faire
moins aussi dans le rapport du Secours
Catholique vous voyez il y a un chiffre
qui ressort c'est qu'il y a de plus en
plus d'étrangers qui font partie des
plus démunis auxquels le Secours
Catholique apporte son aide donc
forcément peut-être Front national on
trouve une solution toute faite si on ne
donnait pas d'allocation
ou plutôt un ordonnée uniquement aux
Français ça serait une manière de
répondre à cette question vous voyez
j'ai posé un peu toutes les
la position sur la table maintenant je
vous laisse débattre merci beaucoup
Stéphane je vais commencer avec vous
Patrice douret essayez de comprendre
l'état d'esprit des restos aujourd'hui à
70000 bénévoles vous parlez de
déflagration vous avez les mots très
forts aujourd'hui dans le monde il y a
un grand papier qui restitue un peu les
positions des associations avec ce
contexte d'inflation dans quel état
d'esprit sont vos bénévoles face à cet
hiver difficile qui arrive des arrows
inquiétudes motivés encore une fois
parce que nos 70 000 bénévoles vous les
avez cités et je tiens là encore une
fois de plus à les remercier parce que
nous pouvons extrêmement être
extrêmement fier de ce travail là toutes
nos équipes sont présentes aujourd'hui
nous constatons effectivement une
aggravation de la précarité et je
citerai un seul chiffre il y a eu
beaucoup de chiffres auparavant mais 60%
des 1 million 100000 personnes que nous
accueillons vivent en dessous de la
moitié du seuil de pauvreté c'est-à-dire
avec moins de 551 euros par mois là on
est dans de l'extrême pauvreté donc les
chiffres sont là oui effectivement il y
a une augmentation de la précarité et
nous avions déjà constaté lors de la
crise sanitaire avec une étude que nous
avions réalisée auprès des personnes que
nous accueillons que plus de la moitié
des personnes que nous avons accueillies
déclare avoir eu un impact de la crise
sanitaire sur leur ressources plus 12%
de bénéficiaires donc une demande qui
augmente qui sont les nouveaux publics
est-ce qu'on voit vraiment des nouvelles
personnes qui basculent oui alors cette
précarité c'est bien là aussi que cela
nous inquiète elle a plusieurs visages
elle a d'abord le visage des aînés des
seniors des personnes qui aujourd'hui
reviennent nous voir pensant s'en être
sorti aussi mais elles ont dû
accompagner aider leurs enfants et leurs
petits-enfants tout au long de la crise
sanitaire ces personnes ces personnes-là
reviennent nous voir et puis nous avons
plus de familles monoparentales avec
beaucoup de maman seule qui viennent
nous voir avec leurs enfants et souvent
des enfants en très bas âge dont le
nombre a aussi fortement augmenté le
bébé je parle de bébé qui a nous un
accueillons 110000 et depuis le mois
d'avril effectivement là aussi nous
constatons sur la même période une
augmentation de 25% les jeunes
représentent la moitié des personnes que
nous accueillons ce public aujourd'hui
il est là il est bien présent et il a
des besoins qui sont quotidiens qui sont
là parce qu'effectivement le choix que
l'on évoquait tout à l'heure et beaucoup
plus difficile entre manger choix
fondamental quand même se loger se
chauffer et maintenant de plus en plus
aussi se déplacer y compris vers les
associations de solidarité on va voir
comment vous allez leur venir en aide
avec cette demande ses besoins qui
augmente Jean-Christophe vous vous êtes
passé par les associations la réalité du
terrain vous connaissez 3,6 millions de
personnes accueillies si l'on cumule le
resto du coeur et toutes les banques
alimentaires à quoi fait-on face
précisément quel mot vous mettez sur la
situation qu'on traverse avec cette
vague d'inflation qui fait suite à la
vague de covid le chiffre auquel vous
faites référence c'est le nombre de
personnes qui sont accompagnées
aujourd'hui par les associations d'aide
humanitaire ce chiffre il a pas explosé
ces dernières années comme vous l'avez
très bien expliqué le gouvernement a mis
en place un certain nombre de mesures
qui ont permis de maintenir la pauvreté
un un taux certes important mais qui n'a
pas exploité plus un million de pauvres
dus à la crise sanitaire vous récupère
c'est une vraie difficulté pour nous
enfin collectivement d'être en capacité
de mesurer en fait l'évolution de la
pauvreté les derniers chiffres de
l'Insee font état d'une pauvreté qui est
à peu près à peu près stable ces
dernières années donc sans explosion en
revanche ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui et
c'est l'effet mécanique de l'inflation
c'est effectivement des files d'attente
dans les unités de distribution
alimentaire qui augmente hier soir
j'étais j'ai rendu visite à une
association qui fait de la distribution
alimentaire pour les étudiants voilà
c'était 700 étudiants qui venaient
demander des colliers alimentaires ce
matin j'étais aux côtés de des Restos du
coeur pour le lancement de leur campagne
annuelle ce qui nous attend selon vous
pauvreté de précarité avec de nouveaux
publics en gros avec plus de pauvres et
plus de pauvres encore plus pauvres
est-ce que vous voyez ça veut dire
plus de pauvres plus pauvres
certainement du fait encore une fois de
l'inflation encore une fois le
gouvernement il est pas resté les bras
ballants c'est-à-dire que il y a un peu
plus d'un an mais j'aimerais vous
entendre sur le diagnostic c'est
important on vient vous allez nous dire
tout ce que vous avez fait et vous
n'avez pas rien faire c'est une évidence
allez-y mais c'est important aussi de le
dire moi ce que je constate aujourd'hui
et on travaille ensemble avec les
associations c'est une augmentation
aujourd'hui des besoins en termes de
d'aide alimentaire la précarité
alimentaire donc augmente vous l'avez
très vous allez très bien décrit le
phénomène c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui
les médailles les ménages les plus
modestes sont les plus impactés parce
que c'est ceux en fait qui font face à
des dépenses contraintes les plus
importantes il se trouve que c'est ces
dépenses contraintes qui ont le plus
augmenté ces derniers mois ça c'est des
chiffres de l'INSEE plus 12% par rapport
à octobre en moyenne pour les prix de
l'alimentation plus 28% 28,7 pour les
viandes surgelées sur un an par rapport
à août 2021 + 19,8% sur le paquet de
pâtes et ça devrait continuer
quand on écoute la grande distribution
Michel-Edouard Leclerc évidemment je
veux pas répercuter mais je pourrais pas
faire autrement plus 10% sur le café en
2023 plus 20 sur les conserves de fruits
donc il va falloir accompagner encore et
encore il faut accompagner enfin je
pense qu'on peut pas accepter que dans
notre pays voilà il y a des ménages des
familles des femmes monoparentales des
familles monoparentales des personnes
âgées des étudiants qui est à renoncé
parfois à des repas à choisir ce qu'ils
vont manger donc à lésiner sur la
qualité manger moins de viande moins de
poissons parfois renoncer à des soins
parfois avoir des difficultés aussi de
logement ou de paiement de facture et
donc il faut qu'on les accompagne alors
je propose qu'on les écoute et je vous
donne la parole dans dans un instant ces
nouveaux publics qui ouvrent la porte
des Restos du coeur pour la première
fois Pierre Michael Carniel s'est rendu
dans l'une des antennes des Restos du
corps à Torcy en Seine-et-Marne en
portage
quelques carottes il y en a pas d'autres
bénévoles Pascal allait donne plusieurs
fois par semaine de son temps et de son
énergie pour distribuer des paniers
alimentaires avec la crise du pouvoir
d'achat elle rencontre de plus en plus
de monde on a tout des profils
on a des étudiants des
[Musique]
retraités aussi de plus en plus de gens
retraités qui ont du mal à finir les
fins de mois elle-même est touchée par
la flambée des prix mais pas question de
renoncer à son engagement c'est pas
parce que la crise nous touche qu'on ne
peut pas non plus
aider les gens
dans un contexte d'inflation et de
factures d'énergie qui explosent les
Restos du Coeur ont décidé d'adapter
leur critères d'inscription et barème
des Restos du cœur ont été modifiés et
l'argile de manière à ce qu'on puisse
prendre en compte un peu plus de
d'éléments à savoir les les
dépenses en énergie en électricité
chauffage etc donc ça va nous amener
forcément plus de monde donc plus de
bouche à nourrir au centre de Torcy le
nombre des bénéficiaires a augmenté de
15% en un an nous avons rencontré trois
personnes qui se retrouvent dans
l'obligation d'y venir depuis quelques
mois
expliquez-nous un peu qu'est-ce que vous
avez dans votre panier aujourd'hui
[Musique]
chaque semaine et vous avez l'habitude
de venir depuis combien malheureusement
on travaille mais on s'en sort pas quoi
donc voilà c'est comme ça puis je suis
enceinte de jumeaux donc oui je suis
auxiliaire de vie pour ben je maintiens
les personnes âgées à leur domicile
l'inflation la crise pour l'achat les
courses à Carrefour c'est deux fois plus
cher qu'avant tout est beaucoup plus
cher qu'avant
je suis à la retraite j'ai une petite
pension et puis ça ça aide toujours là
je vais manger pour 3-4 jours
mais vu la crise actuellement il y a pas
assez de travail et tout donc on est
tous bloqué à la maison donc on se
démerde avec le resto du coeur et nous
n'avons pas les grands revenus vraiment
on est vraiment au bord de la faillite
quoi ouais c'est toi avec les enfants
c'est vraiment difficile
ce jour-là plus de 400 personnes ont
bénéficié de cette distribution
alimentaire
bonsoir pierre d'arriville merci d'être
là il y a forcément de la politique sur
un sujet comme ça ou au fond il faudrait
une forme d'union nationale il y a
forcément de la politique puisque la
politique elle doit répondre aux besoins
aux enjeux au défi et donc je crois que
c'est là qu'elle doit justement trouver
sa place pour s'exprimer pour apporter
une solution comment vous analysez la
situation je rencontre ce que vous venez
de montrer dans le reportage c'est à
dire on a le niveau de la mer qui monte
et
des gens qui sont sous l'eau parce qu'il
y a des bénévoles qui sont eux-mêmes
impactés par la question de la hausse
des prix et qui sont souvent modestes et
qui peuvent peut-être même pas continuer
je parle sous votre contrôle à aider la
question se pose il y a des dilemmes qui
se posent la question est simple
aujourd'hui nous avons des bénévoles qui
sont aussi très impactés par les
dépenses de d'énergie et notamment de
carburant je l'évoquais ce matin avec
Monsieur le Ministre aujourd'hui nous
avons des bénévoles qui sont vous l'avez
vu aussi très concernés par la hausse
des prix qui sont des bénévoles modestes
souvent qui ne sont pas imposable et qui
sont parfois même des personnes
accueillies au resto du coeur qui
donnent du temps qui créent qui ont
réussi à créer ce lien social
aujourd'hui c'est très simple j'ai des
bénévoles encore un ce matin je
l'évoquais qui m'a appelé pour me dire
moi j'arrête je peux plus me déplacer
pour aller faire des formations
rencontrer des producteurs locaux allez
tout simplement dans mon centre
d'activités je ne peux plus me déplacer
parce que le carburant est trop cher il
y a une mesure fiscale et là on est dans
le cœur du débat à l'Assemblée nationale
qui est la réduction d'impôts dont on
pourra éventuellement
on y va pierre d'arrivée de vous voyez à
quoi on fait allusion une réduction
d'impôt pour les bénévoles non
imposables elle avait été adoptée lors
du débat budgétaire retiré par le
gouvernement qui ne l'a pas retenu dans
sa version finale de 49-3 regretté
la transformation au crédit d'impôt ça
ça c'est regrettable vous l'avez vous
l'avez souligné dans les lycées
sur ce que peut la politique nous avons
un désaccord avec Monsieur le Ministre
des désaccords même je dois dire et
c'est nécessaire que on puisse s'en
expliquer alors le repas 1 euro dans les
CROUS pour les étudiants précaires on va
en parler dans un instant la
revalorisation des bourses à 4% pour la
rentrée 2022 des aides exceptionnelles à
100 euros est-ce que vous pourrez dire
il y a des choses qui vont dans le bon
sens ou faut tout revoir tout ce
que bénéfique pour la vie quotidienne
des gens moi je le prends il y a pas de
souci là-dessus mais on a des problèmes
structurels on a un problème de salaire
on a un problème de niveau du SMIC on a
un problème de niveau des pensions ça a
été pointé à part les gens qui viennent
au resto du coeur qui parfois
travaillent et n'arrive pas avec leur
salaire à vivre correctement et donc on
est on est on vit mal aujourd'hui avec
le SMIC on a des métiers mal reconnus
ils ont été cités dans dans votre
reportage donc je crois qu'il y a des
choix quand même fort à faire de ce
point de vue là il y a l'Assemblée
nationale aura j'espère l'occasion de
les faire dans les temps qui viennent
voilà
1600 euros
du SMIC et des salaires qui est tout à
fait nécessaire pour mieux rémunérer le
travail il y a je crois la nécessité de
pas abîmer non plus un certain nombre de
droits sociaux je pense aux droits à
l'assurance chômage qui vient d'être
rabotée de 25% dans sa durée par par le
gouvernement et puis il y a des mesures
à prendre pour les étudiants j'ai bien
vu ce qu'il y avait été fait par par le
gouvernement manifestement ça ne suffit
pas
suffit pas et donc il faut poser la
question d'un revenu étudiant
aujourd'hui c'est une question qui est
posée d'une allocation d'autonomie pour
les étudiants Jean-Christophe con vous
allez répondre il y a des questions
structurelles sur les salaires sur
l'assurance chômage et puis il y a des
questions plus conjoncturelles sur la
crise des étudiants Étienne matinée
est-ce que vous pouvez nous décrire le
quotidien d'un étudiant qui n'a pas ses
parents derrière lui et qui doit
financer ses études aujourd'hui face à
la flambée des prix aujourd'hui on a
tout type de profils d'étudiants mais ce
qu'on observe nous puisque vous l'avez
rappelé on est en effet la principale
organisation étudiante de la phase on a
aussi une organisation qui menons des
projets concrets sur le terrain on a 37
épiceries sociales et solidaires et ce
qu'on observe dans ces épiceries c'est
évidemment une augmentation de la
fréquentation mais surtout une
diminution une une
diminution de de la condition de la vie
en fait des étudiants qu'est-ce qui est
le plus dur c'est carrément de se
nourrir ou d'arriver à se loger
qu'est-ce qui est le problème principal
enfin voilà il y a les agorets et nous
on loge aussi des étudiants nous-mêmes
c'est-à-dire qu'on a des dispositifs ou
nos bénévoles chez nous donnent leur
canapé pour les étudiants qui n'arrivent
pas à se loger parce que soit les prix
sont trop hauts soit parce qu'il y a
juste pas d'offres et ça c'est des
choses qui sont absolument inadmissibles
enfin en tout cas que nous on comprend
pas c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas heureux
d'ouvrir les agoriens on n'est pas
heureux de mettre ça en place ouvrir des
Agora parce qu'il y a des lieux
d'accueil il y a eu il y a eu aussi sur
l'aspect alimentation des guichets
alimentaires pour les étudiants en plus
dans le pays 5 nouvelles structures
c'est suffisant
en tout cas
nous ce qu'on va essayer
les banques alimentaires en France nous
les étudiants aujourd'hui souvent les
dispositifs ils sont dans les grandes
villes ils sont déjà enfin à destination
d'étudiants qui qui ont un certain
nombre dispositifs 02 et aujourd'hui je
le rappelle quand il y a 60% des
étudiants à l'université mais 40% qui
n'y sont pas et juste vous parliez du
CROUS aujourd'hui ce qu'on observe quand
même c'est que il y a un certain nombre
de dispositifs en effet qui doivent être
mis par le CROUS sur la question
alimentaire mais qu'aujourd'hui le CROUS
n'est pas assez financé pour je vais
mettre en place je pense notamment aux
icerus à 1 euro qui est un dispositif
incroyable
généraliser qui qui continue et qui
marche très bien si je puis dire
exactement mais du coup on a des CROUS
qui aujourd'hui n'arrive plus à le
financer et on a vu l'assurer les
réseaux sociaux sont impactés
financièrement par ces mesures je vous
propose monsieur le ministre de répondre
à deux paquets de questions sur les
étudiants d'abord et puis sur les
réformes plus structurelles attendues
par par la gauche notamment d'abord sur
les étudiants vous avez débloqué une
enveloppe de 10 millions aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que ça va changer qui va en
bénéficier comment ça va fonctionner
d'abord c'est une première réponse
d'urgence face à la situation je pense
qu'on peut pas satisfaire de la
situation que que vous décrivez et la
situation d'un grand nombre de nos
étudiants qui vivent aujourd'hui dans la
précarité encore une fois qui saute des
repas qui mangent moins qui renonça des
soins qui ont des difficultés à ce à se
loger donc face à cette situation on a
débloqué de l'argent pour soutenir les
réseaux d'aide supplémentaires qui font
un travail remarquable moi je fais
partie de ceux je viens du secteur
associatif et je fais partie de ceux qui
pensent que la solidarité dans en
matière de solidarité et pouvoir public
ne peuvent pas tout et ne doivent pas
tout faire qu'on a besoin de soutenir et
de mettre en œuvre cette chaîne de
solidarité avec de l'initiative privé
avec avec les associations
pendant le confinement qui ne sont pas
allés dans les banques alimentaires dans
les centres alimentaires aujourd'hui
avec l'essence qui augmente on ne prend
plus sa voiture forcément parce qu'on a
plus les moyens de se déplacer jusqu'à
un centre dans les zones enclavées par
exemple dans les zones rurales qu'est-ce
qu'on fait après on va vers les gens
c'est à dire que je suis des
associations comme les Restos du Coeur
aujourd'hui mettre en place des
dispositifs itinérants on a des
collectivités qui font la même chose des
CCAS un réseau aujourd'hui de centre
communaux d'action sociale sur
l'ensemble du territoire qui vient en
aide à la population et je reviens aux
10 millions d'euros qu'on a bloqués ils
vont permettre d'acheter à court terme
300 000 colis alimentaires d'une semaine
pour les étudiants donc c'est une
réponse d'urgence qui est pas suffisante
puisqu'on voit bien qu'on a un problème
de ce public étudiant on espère voilà
d'ici d'ici d'ici au début d'année
prochaine enfin on va voir on va
travailler avec avec les réseaux ma
collègue Sylvie retaillot en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur va réunir aussi
les associations d'étudiants elle a
lancé une concertation sur la vie
étudiante de façon générale notre
objectif derrière c'est d'apporter des
réponses structurelles alors justement
le structurel on y vient d'arriville il
vous dit au fond il faut tout simplement
augmenter les salaires le SMIC en
particulier ne pas toucher aux
allocations chômage en tout cas alors
versement dans dans le temps ça c'est
des sujets qui existent le plan pauvreté
il y avait un projet de revenu universel
de solidarité où on en est alors moi je
porte un projet qui s'appelle la
solidarité à la source qui est une
modernisation de notre système de
prestation sociale cette prestation
sociale on les a revalorisées de 4% cet
été on a mis en place un certain nombre
d'aides là aussi pour répondre à
l'urgence et parallèlement on essaye de
et on travaille à une réforme
structurelle d'ampleur qui va viser à la
fois à lutter contre le non recours
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de
personnes dans notre pays exactement qui
ont droit à un certain nombre d'aides et
qu'ils n'y ont pas recours et donc on va
travailler sur son en cours on va
travailler aussi contre la fraude parce
qu'on a un sujet aussi notre système
aujourd'hui qui est complexe qui est
lisible il amène d'une recours mais il
amène aussi de la fraude et l'idée c'est
vraiment de faire en sorte que ce
système soit beaucoup plus efficace
alors Patrice entre on a du court terme
d'urgence on a vu 60 millions 10
millions pour les étudiants et puis du
plus long terme ça vous semble adapté
suffisant alors aujourd'hui les restos
du cœur en alerté effectivement parce
que nous répondons à une urgence qui est
là cette urgence elle est extrêmement
précise lorsqu'on accueille une personne
qui ne serait-ce qu'a cosmique vous
enlevez le montant d'un loyer vous
enlevez les dépenses d'énergie il ne
reste quasiment plus rien donc
effectivement plutôt que de ne faire que
constater on a pris nos responsabilités
et préparer l'avenir c'est notre
bénévole l'a dit c'est accueillir ces
personnes en prenant en compte leurs
dépenses d'énergie pour les accueillir
plus en nombre et surtout plus fortement
c'est mettre en place un programme sur
la petite enfance c'est mettre en place
un programme sur la qualité alimentaire
tout ça ce sont des millions d'euros que
nous avons dépensé les restos ça c'est
nous
parlerons et la responsabilité qu'on a
pris c'est d'être toujours ce que font
les restos du début constaté alerter et
faire expliquez-moi l'essentiel de vos
recettes si je puis dire ce sont les
dons de vos ressources ou vous devez
aussi acheter peut-être en gros et donc
lié à la hausse de l'énergie et à la
hausse de l'alimentation vous êtes aussi
directement impacté par la ressources et
la générosité du public qui a toujours
été présent pour soutenir les restos du
cœur aujourd'hui plus d'un tiers de ce
que nous distribuons un produit
alimentaire et un produit de première
nécessité provient d'achat que nous
réalisons c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
les achats que nous faisons nous les
payons avec des prix plus chers vous la
laissez vous avez cité le prix des pâtes
etc etc et ça il est pas question encore
une fois que ce soit les personnes que
l'on accompagne qui en subissent quoi
que ce soit en termes de conséquences
à des prix plus attractifs ou c'est le
prix du marché on achète on essaie
d'acheter de manière négocier avec des
prix nationaux mais on va de plus en
plus vers des producteurs locaux parce
qu'il faut les soutenir et nous
distribuerons gratuitement et il est
évident qu'aujourd'hui lorsqu'on a ces
personnes qui viennent et qui n'ont
quasiment plus rien à vivre notre seul
responsabilité c'est de continuer à les
aider pour ça effectivement il faut du
soutien et le soutien de l'État que nous
attendons là c'est cette transformation
de la réduction d'impôts en crédit
d'impôt pour que les bénévoles non
imposables ne soient pas
après je vous promets je vous passe la
parole vient d'arriver mais on a le
ministre les bénévoles non imposa
bénéficie d'un crédit d'impôt pour leur
frais kilométrique on parle de ça c'est
dans la loi déjà un amendement a été
voté mais le gouvernement la retiré on
est d'accord c'est ça dont on parle
absolument c'est ça dont on parle est-ce
que vous le regrettez sachant que je
précise c'est pas la fin de la navette
budgétaire
que lorsque l'état donne un euro
d'argent public au réseau du cœur nous
déployons 5 à 6 euros d'action sociale
on est véritablement aussi sur une
action d'investissement social parce
qu'encore une fois vous l'avez cité on a
une crise 600 je décrit si ce sont
enchaînés on n'est pas à l'abri demain
d'avoir besoin du renfort du tissu
associatif
par les députés plusieurs choses avant
de répondre à votre question la première
c'est que un tiers de l'aide alimentaire
qui est pourvu par nos associations
vient de l'Union européenne ce qu'on
appelle le fead maintenant le Fond
Social Européen qui finance cette aide
alimentaire deuxièmement l'effort des
pouvoirs publics en année pleine c'est
près de 900 millions d'euros
c'est-à-dire que
pour l'aide alimentaire
c'est une dépense fiscale c'est les dons
dont on parle monsieur Douai et donc
c'est la défiscalisation qui existe déjà
pour l'aide alimentaire et puis c'est
les crédits de l'aide alimentaire je
l'ai dit on les a triplés cette année
pour soutenir les réseaux d'aide
alimentairement voter non repris et
c'est voilà le pouvoir du 49 3 si j'ose
dire pourquoi parce que on fait déjà
beaucoup pour aider et soutenir les
bénévoles des associations pierre
d'arrêt ville on entend le ministre il y
a déjà beaucoup d'efforts des pouvoirs
publics les enveloppes sont conséquentes
pour l'urgence sociale alimentaire il y
a des accompagnements plus larges avec
cette solidarité à la source on entend
aussi l'État ne peut pas tout dans le
domaine les Restos du Coeur font des des
grosses grosses grosses voilà actions et
d'investissement de façon autonome vous
vous saluer au fond cette association
publique privée en matière de solidarité
oui je dirais pas public privé c'est
public et associative qui effectivement
est un couple qui qui doit qui doit
fonctionner parce que l'engagement des
femmes et des hommes au service de la
solidarité et c'est un engagement
valeureux courageux
qui est profondément humain et je crois
qu'il faut il faut l'encourager c'était
le sens de leur rendement d'ailleurs
qu'il y avait été adopté par par le
Parlement et je regrette que dans ce
moment où il y a une majorité relative
ou normalement on devrait un peu plus
écouter ce que disent les députés en
réalité c'est l'inverse qui se passe à
l'occasion de l'examen de ce budget du
budget de la Sécu etc je crois que
franchement on peut pas accepter ça
voilà la conjoncture des déficites qui
sont majeurs qui se creuse les
institutions internationales qui sont
dans votre portage c'est à dire une
situation de crise profonde pour des
femmes et des hommes des familles des
enfants sombre
de dire bon ben nous écouter on a fait
notre part maintenant le reste c'est le
mouvement associatif qui va s'en occuper
tant bien que mal je crois qu'on peut
pas fonctionner comme ça il faut que les
tasses au rendez-vous de ses
responsabilités
encore l'état qui doit donner plus
fléchi plus
nous ce qu'on croit c'est que en effet
on est présent être présent pour faire
du tutorat pédagogique oui être présent
pour lutter contre l'isolation sociale
oui par contre nous-mêmes et des
psychologiquement les étudiants
nous-mêmes et des
étudiants à se nourrir à se loger enfin
ce n'est pas notre rôle et c'est pas au
rôle des étudiants de céder eux-mêmes
sur ces volets là en tout cas et nous ce
qu'on croit c'est qu'en effet il faut
une réforme des bourses monsieur le
minis cela dit il y a une concertation
sur la vie étudiante qui était ouverte
on a énormément d'attente concernant
cette réforme des bourses structurelles
pour l'ensemble des étudiants étudiantes
pour la rentrée 2022 c'est pas suffisant
pour les bourses en tout cas
initiative avec les collectivités on a
montré depuis trois ans qu'on était
personne sur le bord du chemin qu'on
était qu'on était capable de mobiliser
de l'argent public pour aider et pour
renforcer la solidarité dans notre pays
on est encore une fois en dialogue
constant et on continuera à le faire
dans les semaines les mois qui viennent
moi je suis ministre des Solidarités je
m'occupe de la lutte contre la pauvreté
on est en train de mettre en place une
stratégie une nouvelle stratégie de
lutte contre la pauvreté on la construit
avec l'ensemble des acteurs vous diriez
que le bilan parce que le plan progrès
il a 4 ans déjà il est satisfaisant non
on fait on en fait d'Emmanuel Macron
dans ton se souvient lancé avec
on aurait aimé faire reculer la pauvreté
on a fait que la stabiliser dans un
contexte de crise qui était extrêmement
extrêmement difficile et qu'à regarder
ce qui se passe ailleurs dans les autres
pays de l'Union européenne dans les
autres pays
le CDE la pauvreté elle a augmenté donc
c'est bien que les mesures qui ont été
prises ont été efficaces maintenant il
faut aller plus loin c'est pour ça qu'on
ce plan qu'on va continuer d'un revenu
universel ça c'est abandonné on va
réformer notre système de prestation
sociale pour le rendre plus efficace
pour le rendre aussi incitatif à la
reprise du travail pour s'assurer que
d'activité chaque personne dans notre
pays bénéficie d'un revenu qui lui
permet de de vivre mais encore une fois
enfin moi je pense pas que la société à
l'équipe quand elle donne une allocation
à des personnes qui sont en difficulté
nous notre objectif c'est la Société du
Plan d'emploi c'est donner du travail
aux personnes qui aujourd'hui n'en n'ont
pas et il s'avère que il y a beaucoup
d'employeurs aujourd'hui qui ont des
postes qui ne sont pas pourvu rien que
dans le secteur dont j'ai la
responsabilité il y a des dizaines de
milliers de postes dans les métiers du
soin du lien de l'accompagnement qui
sont pas pourvus et il faut qu'on puisse
aussi
au président des Restos du coeur puisque
c'est la 38e aujourd'hui le clip de des
restos sera dévoilé demain c'est ça
qui nous regardent faites un don
j'imagine bien évidemment ceux qui
peuvent encore une fois ce qu'ils
veulent et surtout ce qu'ils peuvent la
crainte que l'on a aussi c'est que nos
ressources et notamment la générosité du
PIC ne soit pas au rendez-vous beaucoup
de gens qui donnent son modèle
des problèmes d'approvisionnement ça ça
va aller je ne sais pas encore une fois
aujourd'hui il y en a de telles
incertitudes sur nos approvisionnements
nos ressources et surtout sur le niveau
de précarité que l'on attend des
ruptures d'approvisionnement ont fait en
sorte que non je vous assure que on est
passé en quelques mois d'une commande
alimentaire j'allais dire chaque semaine
environ 2 millions
on a glissé vers les deux millions et
des produits vous pouvez plus acheter
par exemple
on a des produits qui sont effectivement
en pénurie mais qui sont pas uniquement
liés à l'inflation on a les problèmes de
climat aussi cet été on les achète
beaucoup plus cher 70 000 sont là et
bien là
encore une fois je veux rester confiant
et optimiste parce que vous l'avez vu
nos bénévoles dans votre reportage ils
sont souriants ils sont là et notre
responsabilité là aussi c'est
d'accueillir les personnes qui comptent
sur nous avec le sourire merci beaucoup
merci
à ce débat pour faire un don au Resto du
Coeur Resto du Coeur point org merci
monsieur le ministre d'avoir accepté le
jeu du débat et Merci à VOUS Etienne
Matignon pour la phase dire d'arrêt
ville vous êtes un peu ici chez vous on
va accueillir à présent une philosophe
c'est l'une des rares voix les plus
innovantes et les plus originales de la
philosophie politique contemporaine elle
est engagée pour la cause animale et
l'écologie on a besoin de ses lumières
pour comprendre les enjeux du débat sur
la corrida corrompt à les députés après
demain dans l'hémicycle Corinne
Perruchon Peluchon nous rejoindre dans
un tout petit instant après l'invitation
signée ce soir par Marco pommier
si on vous invite Corinne Peluchon c'est
pour avoir votre avis sur un débat qui
attise les passions la corrida faut-il
oui ou non l'interdire danser
départementaux 1 qui font de la
résistance les députés doivent trancher
cette semaine dans les arènes de
l'assemblée qui êtes-vous réellement
est-ce que vous êtes de ceux qui
cautionnent la torture et l'exécution
publique d'un animal ou de ceux qui
s'élèvent contre ce qu'il faut bien
appeler une barbarie il y a des mille
sujets qui sont de mon pas vu bien plus
prioritaire que de montrer du doigt
cette pratique culturelle et ancestrale
Corinne Peluchon vous êtes philosophe
professeur à l'université Gustave Eiffel
engagez-vous l'êtes sur l'écologie et la
cause animale dans votre dernier livre
pour l'amour des bêtes vous dialoguer
avec Jocelyne Porcher ancienne éleveuse
devenue sociologue plus qu'un dialogue
une opposition éthique sur la mise à
mort des animaux pour manger leur chair
au fond vous et de répondre à une
question abyssale a-t-on le droit de
tuer les animaux à mes yeux la prise en
compte des intérêts des animaux dans
toutes nos politiques publiques et
toutes nos activités et la clé pour
réenclencher un processus
civilisationnel que j'appelle l'âge du
vivant l'âge du vivant forcément
incompatible avec la corrida il faudrait
l'interdire dites-vous mais une question
nous frappe ce soir comment expliquer
que ce que vous considérez comme une
tortue et un bain de sang symbolise pour
d'autres une glorification du taureau et
une simple mise en scène codifiée de la
mort toute la corrida est un art parce
qu'elle met en scène énormément de
nuances et de référence culturelles
historiques traditionnel philosophique
et humaniste des aficionados qui
défendent la tradition culturelle quand
les anticoridas appellent au respect du
vivant et de la nature mais n'est-ce pas
dans la nature même du taureau que
combattre Corinne Peluchon et comment
expliquer que la cause animale soit
devenue si importante aux yeux de
certains à vous la parole
bonsoir Corinne Peluchon et merci
beaucoup d'être parmi nous vous êtes je
le disais parmi les pionnières il y en a
d'autres mais sur la réflexion
philosophique sur la cause animale
philosophe engagé on va revenir sur ce
que vous appelez l'âge du vivant et
l'éthique de la vulnérabilité mais
comment en tant que philosophe vous
regardez ce débat sur la corrida ici à
l'Assemblée nationale mais je crois je
trouve qu'il est bienvenu parce que ce
n'est pas la première fois mais c'est
peut-être la première fois qu'il est à
ce point près de
d'engager tout le monde j'espère
d'aboutir mais je trouve qu'il est
bienvenu parce qu'on peut dire
évidemment il y a la guerre il y a la
précarité on l'a vu dans votre émission
mais la question animale concerne les
animaux mais nous concerne aussi nous
humains ce que nous faisons à des êtres
sensibles pour un plaisir et au nom de
la tradition mais les traditions doivent
être mises en question justement au nom
du progrès au nom du programme oral de
la sensibilité et de la reconnaissance
sensibilité animale et bien toutes ces
et doivent entrer en politique et je
crois que c'est le moment parce que la
cause animale c'est aussi une réflexion
sur ce que nous faisons à des êtres que
personne ne change aujourd'hui à
comparer à des machines alors justement
parce que l'animal machine ça a été
pensé par les philosophes des Lumières
un animal chez Descartes machines
destinées à être utilisé domestiquer à
des fins tout simplement d'intérêt pour
les pour les humains ce débat entre la
nature le vivant l'humain dans la nature
et la culture il est très ancien en
philosophie est-ce que est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en tracer les grandes lignes
comment il se tranchent à chaque fois
alors il est très ancien mais il atteint
aujourd'hui une sorte de maturité je
dirais que effectivement c'est vrai
qu'on peut dire qu'en Occident la
plupart des penseurs mais il y a des
exceptions on considérait l'humain à la
lumière de la rationalité du Logos
raison langage articulé et donc on
pensait préparation de l'humain et des
autres vivants c'était au cœur d'un
humanisme que Claude lévi-straux se
trouvait fondé sur l'amour-propre et
responsable de toutes les
discriminations mais c'est vrai vous
parlez de Descartes mais ça séparation
entre la matière et la pensée était
surtout épistémologique c'est pas et
puis à l'époque on n'est pas dans
l'industrialisation par exemple
aujourd'hui donc je crois que quand il
dit il faut nous rendre comme maître et
ce possesseur la nature souvent en
oublie le com c'est parce qu'à l'époque
l'humain et le prolétaire de la création
et que les êtres ne vivent pas très
longtemps comme montagne on se rappelle
qu'il se demandait combien d'enfants
elle avait eu parce que beaucoup étaient
morts à la naissance donc du coup le
contexte a changé mais c'est vrai qu'il
y a une tendance à opérer en dualisme
entre la nature d'un côté la culture de
l'autre et à penser d'exceptionnalité de
l'humain alors aujourd'hui il s'agit pas
de dire que les humains sont comme des
animaux mais de trouver que non
seulement les frontières entre les
humains les animaux se sont un petit peu
ont été remises en question parce que
les animaux aussi ont une culture les
animaux sont des êtres sensibles ont une
subjectivité il y a toujours quelqu'un
derrière la fourrure elle est plumes ce
sont des êtres individuelles même si ce
ne sont pas des consciences
représentationsnelles étant plutôt de
droite ou de gauche mais ce sont des
consciences quand même on donc ce qu'ils
sont leurs besoins de base donc et aussi
leur subjectivité nous oblige à les
détenir en respectant au moins ses
besoins de base et leur subjectivité il
a fallu attendre 2015 pour que dans la
loi l'animal soit consacré comme un être
vivant doué de sensibilité seulement
c'est très tard comment vous expliquer
au fond que les associations et prêcher
pendant si longtemps dans le désert et
est-ce qu'on est en train de changer
d'époque sur la question animale alors
il y avait quand même au code pénal en
reconnaissait des 76 le caractère
sensible d'un
qui devait pas être placé dans des
conditions justement s'opposant à son
bien-être quand même il y avait des
choses mais il y avait des
contradictions entre le code pénal et le
code civil c'est vrai alors pourquoi
aujourd'hui la question animale s'impose
dans la société pas seulement en France
partout dans les pays d'Europe et aux
États-Unis etc et bien parce que je
crois
les frontières morales qu'on a tracé
entre ceux qui ne disent d'une tueras
point et ce dans la mort provoqué ne
serait rien ont été brouillés mais
surtout je crois que à la lumière de
l'industrialisation de l'élevage et en
raison aussi de la démocratie et de
notre demande en produits animalier et
bien l'intensité de la souffrance
animale le nombre de vies sacrifiées et
sont énormes et je crois que la la
souffrance infligée aux animaux et un
coup de projecteur sur un modèle de
développement
fondé sous l'exploitation sans limite
des autres vivants et de la nature et ça
ça choque et justement donc la question
animale elle est importante pour les
animaux mais elle est aussi stratégique
parce qu'elle est aussi le coeur d'un
combat ou d'une volonté de changer de
modèle de développement un modèle de
développement dont les
contre-productivités environnementales
sociales sanitaires
et la vulnérabilité de la planète qui
nous permet une prise de conscience sur
le vivant et l'animalité dans la nature
avec les humains voilà et puis je pense
qu'il y a une révolution anthropologique
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les personnes
prennent conscience de cette communauté
de vulnérabilité que nous partageons
avec les autres vivants qui sont
différents nous mais qui ont quand même
des lignes de similitude avec nous et
cela engage une autre manière d'habiter
la terre et de cohabiter avec les autres
vivants donc l'écologie elle-même et la
cause animale ne sont plus rivales comme
elle l'était encore il y a quelques
années ou les parfois les écologistes
c'était chasseurs et il y avait une
opposition entre la protection de
l'espèce du groupe et la protection des
individus alors ce débat c'est
passionnant il est au centre de votre
correspondance dans ce dans ce petit
livre qui s'appelle pour l'amour des
bêtes aux éditions mialées barreaux
correspondance avec une
n'impose pas ce qui est plus qui nous
concerne tous et toutes c'est que les
conditions démographiques notre poids
démographique et les conditions
d'élevage et d'abattage aujourd'hui pour
nourrir 8 milliards pratiquement
l'individus et en raison de ses faire
vous voyez en Chine il va y avoir un une
sorte de gratte-ciel avec plein d'étages
26 étages 650 000 cochons enfin c'est
vraiment une aberration et bien cela ces
conditions industrielles obligent toute
personne même qui n'est pas végane et
végétarienne à se poser la question de
la provenance de la viande et des
conditions qu'on impose à ces êtres
vivants pour encore une fois un plaisir
substitua parce qu'il est possible
aujourd'hui de se nourrir sans produits
animalier ou au moins de réduire sa
consommation qui serait une bonne chose
écologique à mettre fin à toute
consommation animale et moi je veux pas
faire une tyrannie du bien et imposer
mon choix de vie aux autres il s'agit de
se poser cette question
qui es-tu toi pour faire couler le sang
des bêtes dans ce contexte là ou en plus
l'élevage industriel a des conséquences
pour les animaux mais aussi pour la
planète mais aussi pour la déforestation
puisque la déforestation est quand même
liée aussi à la production de soja pour
le bétail américain etc et européen donc
du coup c'est quand même une question
transversale totale pour ainsi dire et
je crois que il s'agit pas d'opposer des
points de vue si tranchées mais quand
même de s'interroger sur ce qu'on fait
chaque jour et c'est en ce sens que cet
ouvrage est passionnant parce que vous
pensez aussi un peu contre vous-même en
vous confrontant vraiment à cet éleveuse
Jocelyne Porcher qui n'est pas d'accord
avec vous et c'est passionnant et on
comprend en quoi la question animale et
au combien une question philosophique
merci merci de nous avoir accompagné
pour prendre un peu de hauteur avant ce
débat corrida qui aura lieu jeudi dans
l'hémicy tient on va en parler rester
avec nous parce que dans Palais Bourbon
Express tout à l'heure tout de suite
même Stéphanie Despierre par quelque
chose d'affranchis ce soir va revenir
sur ce débat sur la corrida elle nous
dira pourquoi les insoumis sont dans le
rôle de l'arroseur arrosée le coup de
gueule de l'enseignant Yanis roder ce
soir après le rapport accablant sur
l'abandon la solitude criant de Samuel
Paty avant son assassinat puis le parti
pris de l'écho de Fanny guinochet sur un
record historique lui de la rémunération
des grands patrons nos affranchis des
voici bonsoir et merci d'être là
Stéphanie on commence avec vous vous
nous parlez d'obstruction parlementaire
c'est une stratégie que les insoumis
connaissent bien ils s'en sont fait un
peu les spécialistes mais cette fois
elle leur revient comme un boomerang oui
alors déposer des dizaines des centaines
voire des milliers d'amendements pour
créer l'embouteillage ralentir le débat
sur un projet de loi c'est depuis 2017
la marque de fabrique des insoumis ici à
l'Assemblée ils ont souvent été accusés
de faire de l'obstruction mais cette
technique aujourd'hui leur revient comme
un bon gant un boomerang jeudi c'est
leur journée de niche parlementaire
l'Assemblée nationale va donc débattre
des propositions de la France insoumise
mais il y a une avalanche d'amendements
cette fois ce sont donc les insoumis qui
créent à l'obstruction je déplore
l'obstruction anti-démocratique qui est
fait sur l'unique journée que nous avons
pour choisir l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale sur cette unique
journée on nous retrouvons avec 26
amendements sur hubert-files 112
amendements sur le SMIC 230 amendements
sur l'IVG 560 amendements sur la corrida
et je pourrais ensuite continuer avec
les autres textes alors j'ai compté ça
fait presque un millier d'amendements
rien que sur les quatre principales
propositions loi des insoumis c'est
beaucoup c'est vrai ils craignent donc
de ne pas avoir assez de temps pour
débattre de ces textes je vous le
rappelle lors des niches parlementaires
la séance commence à 9 heures elle se
termine à minuit quoi qu'il arrive même
si tous les thèmes n'ont pas été
débattus c'est comme Cendrillon c'est
comme Cendrillon on freine on se
transforme on éteint les lumières c'est
terminé et pour sur l'inscription du
droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution par
exemple il y a 200 amendements à elle
seule la députée à non inscrite manuel
Ménard on a déposé plus de 70 elle
s'oppose au texte mais elle se défend de
toute obstruction je défends mes
convictions en déposant des amendements
ça me semble pas être de l'obstruction
je vous rappelle quand même que la
France insoumise c'était les champions
du monde de l'obstruction le projet de
loi retraite c'est déposé 19000
amendements et pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière sur le projet de loi de
la loopy de défendue par Monsieur
Darmanin on a eu le droit à des
séquences interminables sur le montant
de l'amende forfaitaire délictuelle qui
devait passer de 800 euros à 30 centimes
puis de 800 euros à 50 centimes puis de
800 euros à un euro donc sur le vraiment
en matière d'obstruction je pense que la
France insoumise a pas vraiment de le
soin de l'État alors chez les
macronistes aussi on s'étrangle en
entendant les insoumis et on dit que
c'est l'hôpital qui se moque de la
charité alors finalement est-ce que
c'est l'arroseur arrosée non c'est pas
pareil rétorque les insoumis
lorsque nous avons déposé beaucoup
d'amendements ça concerne le sujet des
retraites et nous n'étions pas cadrés
par une discussion qui commence à 9
heures et qu'il devait terminer à minuit
d'accord et le sujet des retraites était
un sujet d'intérêt général sur lequel
nous pensions d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement n'avait pas si pris le
temps dans le cadre de la niche
parlementaire le fait de déposer des
amendements ne dis pas que ça prend plus
de temps ça empêche que ça ait lieu
voilà parce qu'à minuit on doit arrêter
alors qui a déposé tous ces amendements
alors les amendements viennent un peu de
tous les bords sur la corrida c'est
surtout le rassemblement national qui en
a déposé en cascade beaucoup viennent
aussi des républicains sur le SMIC et
surtout sur l'IVG là une centaine d'un
moment viennent exclusivement de quatre
députés qui sont très hostiles à
l'avortement à droite mais les
républicains ne veulent surtout pas être
taxés d'obstruction alors le président
du groupe Olivier marlex tente de
réfréner un peu la créativité de ces
députés je leur ai déjà fait le message
que effectivement on n'est pas là du
tout du tout c'est pas notre intention
de faire la moindre la moindre
obstruction on respecte
cette journée qui est importante pour
chaque groupe sa une journée par an donc
c'est très important il y aura un texte
de la majorité la semaine suivante donc
je vais suggérer
au député de mon groupe de reporter sur
la semaine suivante un certain nombre de
leurs amendements et puis les insoumis
préviennent eux aussi ils renverront le
boomerang si des groupes notamment les
républicains font l'obstruction jeudi
lors de leur niche parlementaire et bien
ils feront pareil et la niche des
républicains c'est le jeudi d'après
d'accord voilà tout le monde est prévenu
en ce qui concerne les niches mais c'est
très important parce que c'est le moment
où un groupe parlementaire à
l'initiative de la loi donc c'est
fondamentale surtout dans cette nouvelle
donne politique si je comprends bien ce
débat corrida il risque de pas avoir
lieu parce que face à toutes ces
amendements cette obstruction ce sera ce
sera sans doute trop tard pour pour la
loi aymeric Caron comment vous réagissez
à ça encore l'abolition de la corrida
portait très justement par Emery Caron
n'appartient pas à un groupe
parlementaire mais à tout le monde donc
de toute façon et c'est une question qui
sera reposée très bientôt et qui de
toute façon est entré dans la société en
France c'est déjà une forme de victoire
de l'avoir porté dans l'opinion oh ça
fait déjà quelques années de toute façon
que les sondages sont quand même là près
de 80% des Français veulent l'abolition
de la corrida et moi je soutiens
complètement à fond cette loi et comment
vous voilà vous regardez le fait que
finalement et ben les députés risquent
un peu d'esquiver pour ne pas avoir à
voter
oui mais ça changera ça changera
consciente oui parce que de toute façon
les corridas les pays où il y a les
régions il y a des corridas vivent de
subventions publiques donc on sait très
bien que elles ont de moins en moins de
succès et que de toute façon la prise en
compte des animaux et le refus de cette
violence
inutile c'est fait consensus de plus en
plus bon vous êtes universitaire vous
enseignez la philosophie la chronique de
Yannis roder va vous intéresser Yanis
vous vous dit revenir sur ce qu'on
apprend de ce rapport de la date la
sous-dérection sur les affaires
terroristes révélées par Le Parisien
concernant le contexte qui a précédé
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
comme tous les mardis c'était revu de
presse dans ma classe et une élève ma
questionné elle m'a demandé ce pourquoi
on parle encore de Samuel Paty et en
effet vous avez raison le Parisien on a
fait ça une hier du fait de ce rapport
de la date
alors qu'est-ce qu'on apprend dans ce
rapport pas de révélation fracassante
Myriam mais des détails que nous ne
connaissions pas le rapport d'enquête
décrit un professeur inquiet très
inquiet qu'un autre professeur dit alors
ne pas reconnaître quand il a peur il
demandait en effet à d'autres collègues
de le raccompagner chez lui en voiture
chemin qui l'effectue auparavant à pied
aucun n'avait pu le faire le 16 octobre
2020 ce jour-là en sortant du collège
Samuel Paty en Philippe sa capuche il a
mis ses oreillettes dans ses oreilles
peut-être n'a-t-il pas entendu
l'assassin arriver derrière lui ça veut
dire que l'enquête montre qu'il n'a pas
été protégé c'est ça le la défaillance
majeure c'est ça le scandale en fait
c'est ce qui ressort effectivement de ce
rapport c'est ça terrible solitude
malgré l'aide de certains collègues il a
ainsi bénéficié Myriam d'aucune
protection particulière alors que dit
l'article du Parisien le collège est
assaillé de menaces la principale a
alerté la police et le rectorat et
certains semblent donc conscients du
danger c'est aussi le cas de l'agend
d’accueil par exemple
qui se connectait à son emploi du temps
pour voir à quelle heure il sortait il
rentrait de manière à surveiller les
abords du collège alors comment
l'expliquer comment expliquer qu'au fond
malgré toutes ces alertes et tous ces
témoins qui avaient compris qu'il y
avait un vrai problème il n'est pas pu
avoir cette protection alors on peut
vraiment s'interroger Myriam et j'avoue
ne pas comprendre comment cela a été
possible je n'ose imaginer que les
services quel qu'il soit n'est pas pris
avec le sérieux nécessaire les menaces
et ceux qui les proférait en effet ce
n'est pas comme si les attentats
islamistes n'avaient pas été nombreux
depuis 10 ans c'est pas non plus comme
si d'ailleurs je n'avais pas directement
menacé l'école publique
alors comment expliquer cela par un
défaut d'analyse par une sous-estimation
de la menace on va dire je ne sais pas
mais quoi qu'il en soit il me semble que
notre société est aussi capable de
fabriquer de l'amnésie et celle-ci est
peut-être même inversement proportionnel
au choc provoqué par l'événement plus le
choc est fort je vais dire par là que
plus le choc est fort plus certains
semblent vouloir en oublier la nature et
ceux qui en sont à l'origine comme pour
mieux effacer la réalité et peut-être se
rassurer car au moment de l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty personne ne pouvait dire
qu'il ne savait pas ce dont les
islamistes sont capables sachez Myriam
que depuis la rentrée la rentrée de
septembre la presse a fait l'état d'au
moins 5 professeurs menacés dans leur
intégrité physique voire ayant reçu des
menaces de mort au nom d'une lecture
radicale de l'islam sans parler de ceux
dont les noms sont livrés sur son
balancés sur les réseaux sociaux alors
tachons maintenant de ne pas oublier que
terroriser les professeurs jusqu'à
parfois les assassiner n'a rien de
nouveau c'était déjà la stratégie des
islamistes dans l'Algérie des années
j'imagine que voilà vous êtes comme nous
plein d'effroi à la lecture de ce
rapport d'un tout petit mot que de
manière générale faudrait davantage
protéger les professeurs alors Fanny
tout autre sujet aujourd'hui vous
revenez vous aussi sur un rapport d'un
institut pro Synco c'est ça procès
qui est bien révèle un record un nouveau
record historique concernant la
rémunération des grands patrons 52% de
hausse cette année pour la rémunération
des grands patrons tout confondus
c'est-à-dire quand on met le salaire le
bonus les avantages en nature et j'en
passe alors en prenant tout en compte il
apparaît qu'en moyenne ça fait grosso
modo un salaire une rémunération de 8
millions d'euros 7,9 exactement pour les
patrons cette année sur les 120 plus
grands groupes français il y en a quand
même un quart où les patrons les le
dirigeant gagne plus de 5 millions
d'euros comment l'expliquer alors
l'explication c'est tout simple ce sont
les chiffres de proxin veste de l'année
dernière 2021 excellente année après une
année de covid ou l'économie est sous
cloche c'est la reprise et comme une
partie de la rémunération de ses patrons
est d'excès sur les résultats des
entreprises et bien forcément c'est le
jackpot alors qui figure en haut du
palmarès alors il y en a un tout en haut
Carlos Tavares le patron de stelantis
expé ça et vraiment il est en haut parce
qu'il est à 20 millions d'euros c'est ce
que dit le groupe proximinent même que
c'est beaucoup plus et ce niveau de
rémunération a même fait tousser le
Medef c'est vous dire Bruno Le Maire le
ministre de l'Économie et même Emmanuel
Macron quand il était en campagne à
trouver cette rémunération choquante et
excessive Carlos Tavares lui estime que
c'est parfaitement normal ça correspond
à son travail à la stratégie pour
adresser l'entreprise il n'a pas
démérité il était interrogé chez par
France Info il y a quelques semaines à
l'occasion du Mondial de l'auto et il
disait je ne comprends pas pourquoi on
me pose la question il y a qu'en France
où on me pose ce genre de sujet alors
derrière lui mais nettement plus bas
vous avez le patron d'assaut Bernard
Charlès ou encore François Henri Pinault
qui est donc le patron du groupe kering
qui est dans le luxe alors c'est vrai
qu'en France ce sujet est ultra sensible
ultra sensible et d'ailleurs en France
il y a une loi les entreprises publiques
elle y a un plafond pour les patrons
500.000 euros donc vous voyez ça fait
quand même un écart c'est ce que va
toucher le nouveau patron d'EDF alors
que dans les groupes privés finalement
les seules régulateurs ce sont les
actionnaires alors il y a quand même
quelques changements note Proxinvest
c'est que ce sujet de la rémunération
dans les assemblées générales il fait
quand même tousser et on se pose la
question chose qu'avant on ne remettait
pas vraiment en cause là on essaie de
faire attention aux écarts et puis il y
a eu des critères qui ont été instaurées
plus récemment des critères
environnementaux d'égalité sociaux de
gouvernance mais bon on ne peut que s'en
féliciter de cette prise de conscience à
cet tardive mais indispensable quand
tout à l'heure on écoutait le début de
votre émission où on parlait des
Français qui avaient des gros
difficultés à finir leur fin de mois
effectivement ça semble complètement
dans un autre monde merci Fanny
guénynochel brief Eco sur France Info à
retrouver tous les matins vaste question
philosophique que la question de
l'égalité ça la réelle merci beaucoup
Corinne béluchon d'être passé par le
plateau de LCP je rappelle votre
correspondance avec l'éleveuses Jocelyne
Porcher ça s'appelle pour l'amour des
bêtes et c'est aux éditions Mialet et
barreaux remercier les affranchis à très
vite très belle soirée documentaire bien
sûr restez avec nous sur SCP Jean-Pierre
Gratien aux manettes tout de suite à
demain
[Musique]